a new cycle is coming to the Eurogroup
first on leadership today I will inform
finance ministers of the process to
elect a new liberal president I will
launch a call for candidates and my name
will not be on that list after careful
consideration I have decided not to seek
reelection my mandate ends on July 12
from that day there will be a new
president of the Eurogroup second on
policy the Eurogroup brokered the deal
on the five hundred and forty billion
safety net for workers businesses and
sovereigns to cope with the emergency
phase of this crisis on April the 9th we
laid out the principles of the recovery
fund all translated into the German
French proposal and the Commission's
recovery package now we must assess
investment needs ensure complementarity
of national and EU growth plans and
shield the euro from divergent
strategies protecting the euro is as
important as defending the single market
we have to be assured that the euro area
perspective is taken into account in the
way we spend these new resources the
Euro group with its track record of
delivery under tight schedules stands
ready to support leaders in these
difficult negotiation
[Music]